- [Instructor] In
previous videos, we talked
about the dramatic turnaround
in the fourth century
in terms of how Christianity was treated
in the Roman Empire.
As you enter into the fourth
century, it's persecuted
by Diocletian, but then
Constantine takes power.
He's sympathetic to the Christians.
He even convenes them in
order to unify the Christians,
to have a more unified
sense of what it means to be
Christian, in order to
settle things like the Arian
Controversy, and he converts
himself to Christianity.
And as we exit the fourth century,
you have Theodosius,
who makes Christianity
the official religion of the Roman Empire
and then begins to
persecute other religions.
Now, what we're going to do in this video
is continue the narrative,
and in particular,
we're going to see how
there's an evolution between
the church in the west and
the church in the east.
In previous videos, we already talk about
how the Roman Empire itself
is initially administered
between west and east, and
then that administration
becomes more and more formal.
Theodosius is the last emperor
to truly rule both halves.
They start getting ruled separately.
And as you get into the latter
half of the fifth century,
the western empire itself
falls to Germanic conquerors.
Now, in previous videos, we
talk about how the emperors
who rule from Constantinople
consider themselves
to continue the Roman Empire.
They didn't call themselves
the Byzantine Empire,
as we now call them.
They call themselves the Roman Empire.
They considered themselves Roman emperors.
The west falls, as I just mentioned,
into a bunch of Germanic kingdoms.
Justinian is able to
reclaim a lot of the land
formerly lost in the western Roman Empire.
Now, there's some other interesting actors
we see emerging on this map,
and once again, we're
now in the sixth century.
You have these Germanic
tribes, the Visigothic kingdoms
here in modern-day Spain, and
here in modern-day France,
you have the Franks.
And the word France really is referring
to land of the Franks,
another Germanic tribe.
Now, they are able to factor
much, much more relevantly.
And when I say about,
I'm saying over the next
several hundred years in
this eventual division,
culturally and religiously,
between east and west.
As I mentioned in previous videos,
the division, yes, it will
center on notions of language.
In the west, especially in
the church, Latin is used.
In the east, in the church, Greek is used.
There are spiritual debates
that we will touch on
in a few minutes, but there's
also a power struggle.
You have the Byzantine Emperor
seated in Constantinople.
You have the Bishop of
Rome, now known as the Pope,
the Pope of Rome, who considers
themselves more and more
the leader of all of Christianity,
and their argument there
is look, this is the church
that, according to tradition,
was founded by Peter,
first amongst the apostles.
You have the patriarch of Constantinople
and patriarchs of other
significant centers of Christianity
that say wait, hold on a second.
Yes, Bishop of Rome,
you are very important.
But we consider you to
be first amongst equals.
You don't have jurisdiction
over all of Christendom.
Together we have jurisdiction.
And this was, to some degree,
the case under Justinian,
and it was very clear at
this time that the Byzantine
emperor was very powerful, not
just over the temporal realm,
really referring to the
day-to-day material realm,
but also a lot of influence
on the spiritual realm,
which was really supposed to be the domain
of the bishops or the
popes or the patriarchs.
This notion of the pentarchy
was codified in the Justinian
law, this idea that these
five centers of Christianity
really have extra weight and collectively
are really leading Christendom.
Now, as I mentioned,
things get interesting
as we fast forward about 250 years.
So let's go to the year 800.
So, one thing you might notice
is that group in yellow,
the Franks, have now conquered a lot more,
and they're conquering
it under the leadership
of Charlemagne.
At the same time, you
see this green over here.
Islam has dramatically
spread from its founding
in the early seventh
century, all the way now
as we're exiting the eighth century,
to cover most of the Middle East, Persia,
bordering on modern-day Pakistan, India,
north Africa, and even
going into modern-day Spain.
At the same time,
especially because of these
Islamic conquests, the Byzantine Empire
and the Byzantine emperor
is significantly weaker.
So you can imagine the
pope in Rome here saying,
well, who's going to protect me,
especially from my political enemies?
Now, Charlemagne considers
himself something of a protector
of Christianity, and Pope Leo III
goes to him for protection,
and Charlemagne is able
to actually provide it.
And in exchange, or
perhaps in thanks for that,
the pope crowns Charlemagne
as Holy Roman Emperor.
Now, what's significant about this
is it really introduces
a fourth actor here,
because the title Holy Roman Emperor
was intentionally given to say, look,
now you, Charlemagne, you are the heir
to the grandeur of Rome.
You are the heir to the Roman emperors.
Now, you might be saying,
wait, isn't that what
the Byzantine emperors thought they were?
Didn't they think this
was the Roman Empire?
And at that time, their
emperor was an empress.
It was Empress Irene of Athens.
And so once again, this is
creating further tension.
They're using different languages,
Latin versus Greek.
You now have the western
pope recognizing a different,
I guess you could say, Roman
emperor in Charlemagne.
The nature of the west is
becoming more Germanic,
and using the language Latin,
while the nature of the east
is continuing in Greek traditions.
On top of that, what you
have in the year 800,
you're actually in this
period where you've had
several conflicts over
this notion of iconoclasm.
This iconoclasm movement, you could say,
started in 726 when the
Byzantine emperor said,
enough of these images of
Jesus and the Virgin Mary
and other figures of
Christianity in our churches,
citing references in the Old
Testament saying that hey,
we shouldn't have these images.
And so this iconoclasm or
these destroying of icons
starts to begin.
Well, the pope in the west, they say,
hey, we don't think we
have to listen to you.
I am the Bishop of Rome.
I have universal jurisdiction.
And then to add insult
to injury, now, in 800,
you have Charlemagne being
crowned Holy Roman Emperor.
Now, a thread further running through this
is something we've talked
about in a previous video,
this notion of filioque, where in 381,
the Council of Constantinople,
they augment the Nicene Creed
where they say, and we believe
in the Holy Spirit, the Lord
and Giver of Life who
proceeds from the Father.
Well, in the west, they add
the Latin term filioque,
which means and the Son.
This is touching on some of
these notions in the Arian
Heresy where, where does the
Holy Spirit proceed from,
if the Father and Son
are really co-divine,
co-equal, of the same substance,
shouldn't the Holy Spirit
proceed from both rather than just one?
Well, those in the east said, hey,
this isn't what we agreed to,
while those in the west say,
hey, we don't think it's
so important that you agree
to things, because we
have the seat at Rome,
the seat that was established by Peter.